Un idioma puede ser un obstaculo
para un inmigrante en un nuevo país.
Un obstáculo en la
integración a la nueva sociedad.
O puede ser, la puerta de
entrada, a una cultura nueva.
Martín, mi invitado, trata esos
temas en su canal de YouTube.
Creo que es muy interesante, entender
sus opiniones
sobre esas cuestiones.
Steve: Buenos días, buenas tardes.
Hoy tengo el gran placer
de poder hablar con Martín.
Del jardín de Martín.
Martín vive en Alemania y
ayuda a hispanohablantes,
sobre el punto de vista del idioma,
de integrarse en la vida en Alemania.
Quizás tú puedes contarnos
un poco sobre tu actividad,
a partir de ser padre de familia,
de tener hijos.
Martín: Si.
Bueno, primero gracias Steve
por la invitación a esta entrevista.
Exacto.
Tengo 2 canales de YouTube.
El principal se llama
"El jardín de Martín".
Lo inicié apenas llegué
a Alemania a vivir.
Yo vivo acá hace unos
5 años más o menos.
Y lo inicié porque me encontraba
todo el tiempo con gente con
las mismas dudas y obstáculos,
e impresiones o nuevas impresiones,
como expat o como migrante
al llegar a un país como Alemania.
Y ahí es donde voy contando
lo que voy descubriendo.
Entre ellos, el idioma.
Luego abrí un segundo
canal hace poco,
se llama "Martín adquiere un idioma".
Porque al aprender
alemán, a mis 35 años,
luego me vi forzado a averiguar
cómo es que se aprende un idioma.
Porque al comienzo no resultó.
Entonces en ese canal, hablo
exclusivamente sobre
como hago yo, para aprender
alemán y otros idiomas.
Y si, ante todo soy papá.
Siempre digo eso.
Tengo 2 hijos pequeños.
La gente se presenta,
"Yo hago esto".
Yo siempre digo, "Soy papá".
No sé cómo será en Canadá,
pero me imagino que es igual que acá.
En Latinoamérica tú sabes,
que es un poco más fácil a veces,
porque tienes a la
abuela y la nanny, etc.
Acá la paternidad
es un oficio duro.
Donde hay que
dedicarle mucho tiempo.
Steve: Pero, al mismo
tiempo, me parece que tú estás
en una situación
muy distinta de la mía.
Porque yo estudio
idiomas por placer.
Porque me gusta poder estudiar.
Y si lo habló muy mal, no
importa porque soy estudiante.
Soy étudiant, como
se dice en francés.
Entonces yo en mi video, en mi
canal, yo siempre digo a las personas,
que no se preocupen sobre
las cosas básicas del idioma
que son difíciles de aprender,
que vienen después.
Que hay que gozar del idioma,
tener placer en el aprendizaje.
Pero tu situación,
y la situación de muchos
inmigrantes de España, de América Latina,
que llegan a Alemania,
que tienen que buscar trabajo,
que tienen que mejorar
su nivel en el idioma,
yo creo que, el alemán
no es un idioma muy fácil.
Yo no sé si los alemanes son acogedores,
pero creo que hay una diferencia
entre las necesidades prácticas
de alguien que viene de un
país como Alemania,
y alguien que estudia idiomas por gusto.
¿Cuáles son los consejos que tú
puedes darle a tus seguidores?
Martín: Pues hay mucho
que hablar de este tema, ¿no?
Pero un poco repasando mi
historia, para mí no siempre fue fácil.
El primer año fue muy muy duro,
con respecto al idioma.
Yo venía de aprender
inglés estando en Perú,
me metí a estudiar
inglés antes de venir,
porque dije "El inglés lo
voy a aprender más rápido",
y relativamente funcionó.
Y pensé que el alemán iba a
funcionar de la misma manera,
y no fue así.
Yo creo que es porque en el inglés,
todos tenemos una pequeña base
de inglés de la escuela.
El alemán fue muy duro, y poco a poco,
empecé a darme cuenta
que en vez de aprender más,
me iba bloqueando más.
E iban apareciendo como
monstruos de temor de hablar,
se me olvidaban las palabras.
Lo que entendía en clase,
no lo entendía en la calle.
El alemán en clases era totalmente distinto
a lo que yo encontraba en la calle.
Entonces eso fue muy difícil.
Luego, conocí algunos políglotas
en la vida real digamos, en Berlín.
Entre ellos Luca, conocí a varios,
y eso me abrió un poco los ojos.
Porque dije, "Estas personas no son
como
no sé cómo se dice en inglés,
pero en español se dice
"no son ratones de biblioteca".
Steve: En inglés
diríamos "bookworms".
Martín: Bookworms, yeah.
Gusanos de libros, ¿no?
Son personas normales como yo.
Entonces, si ellos pueden,
¿por qué no yo?
Eso fue lo primero
que me abrió los ojos.
Y dije, "Algo estoy haciendo mal".
Lo segundo fue que me topé
con la teoría y la adquisición.
Lo hice a través de un podcast.
En esa época estaba intentando
aprender algo de francés.
Hay un chico que se llama
Hugo, de "Inner french".
Y él en un podcast habla de eso.
Y también me cambio
un poco la perspectiva.
Y lo que yo descubrí, es que
no solamente estaba haciendo
algunas cosas mal, sino
que yo estaba construyendo
delante mío, un filtro afectivo,
no sé cómo se llama
esa hipótesis en inglés,
Steve: Affective filter, lo mismo.
Martín: El affective filter.
Como un muro,
entre el alemán y yo.
Y yo creo que esa,
es la principal dificultad
de los latinoamericanos
cuando llegan a Alemania.
Que el temperamento, la
manera de ser, es muy diferente.
El Latinoamericano, hispanohablante
en realidad, el español también.
Somos muy expresivos, usamos
mucho nuestras manos, nuestra cara.
Para hablar, necesitamos
hablar un poco más alto, ¿no?
Hablamos alto.
No sé, necesitamos como ser muy
claros a la hora de expresar las cosas.
Y el alemán, no es muy
expresivo con sus manos, su cara.
Es un poco más, para los alemanes,
la distancia personal es muy importante.
Y es importante para ellos que
el acercamiento entre dos personas
no sea inmediato,
sino que sea lento.
Entonces para hacer amigos acá,
es diferente que en Latinoamérica.
En Latinoamérica hablas, y el
small talk se da todo el tiempo.
La gente habla en la calle, unos con otros.
Acá es un poco distinto.
Y eso a los Latinoamericanos
les choca un poco.
Porque uno viene acá, pensando que va a
poder practicar el idioma
por todos lados, y no es así.
Toca aprender cómo hacerlo.
Entonces, cuando vez que no
funcionan las cosas como en tu país,
te empiezas a frustrar y
empiezas a levantar algunos muros.
Steve: Yo creo que
hay dos cosas ahí.
Pienso que los alemanes
no son tan distantes.
Pero la cuestión es que tú tienes
que hablar el idioma.
Bastante bien.
Sino el alemán va a
empezar a hablar en inglés.
Es necesario tener
un nivel bastante alto en alemán.
Pero para mí, siempre
han sido relajados, amables.
Martín: Si.
Steve: Quizás menos que en Perú,
o en Brasil.
Que quizás la gente
es más emotiva.
Pero es también una
cuestión, del nivel del idioma.
Y quizás todos los
hispanohablantes son más tolerantes.
Si tú tratas de hablar en español,
a lo mejor el español
no sabe hablar inglés.
Entonces va a
continuar en español.
Pero el alemán,
que sabe bien hablar inglés,
va a cambiar y hablarte en inglés.
Pero una pregunta,
yo cuando intenté estudiar alemán,
porque el alemán tiene cosas gramaticales,
reglas de gramática bastante difíciles.
Die, dem, des, den.
Y yo he tratado de
aprender esas cosas,
a partir de esas tablas.
¿Cómo se dice?
Martín: Tablas.
Steve: Eso no funcionaba.
Cuando yo empecé a escuchar
y hablar, y no preocuparme,
continuando con mis errores,
poco a poco mi nivel ha ido mejorando.
Y yo no sé si tú,
has tratado de aprender
a través de esas tablas,
o hablando, leyendo, escuchando.
¿Cuál era el método
que funcionaba para ti?
Martín: Bueno, antes de responder
esa pregunta solamente quiero decir que
con lo anterior,
no quise decir que
los alemanes son malas personas.
Son buenísimos, muy muy amables,
a mí me han abierto las puertas de su país.
Solamente que la manera de
entrar en la vida de ellos, es distinta.
Steve: Si, seguro.
Martín: Que en Latinoamérica.
Y hay como un choque cultural, ¿no?
Pero con la pregunta
que me haces ahora,
a mí no me funcionan las tablas.
A mí nunca me han funcionado.
Es muy estresante para mí.
Siempre fue como intentar hablar,
y al mismo tiempo mientras hablo,
intentar recordar esa
tabla y hacer la conjugación.
Y no solamente con las
declinaciones de los artículos,
sino la cantidad de vocabulario.
Porque hay idiomas como el español,
donde, a mi modo de ver,
no se usan tantas palabras
como en el daily,
como en el uso diario.
En el alemán se usan muchas
palabras, porque son muy específicos
para describir cosas.
Entonces necesitan
más vocabulario.
Y aprenderte todas esas declinaciones
y ese vocabulario de memoria,
para poder hablar,
para mi es imposible.
A mí lo que me ha funcionado,
es aumentar mi volumen
de leer y escuchar, escuchar
muchísimo y leer mucho.
Y de tanto escuchar,
cuando hablo,
intuitivamente ya
sé cuál es el correcto.
Porque ya lo escuché
tantas veces, que digo
"Esto se dice así.
No voy a pensar
ahora mismo por qué.
Yo ya sé que se dice así,
Porque ya lo
escuché tantas veces."
Steve: Y tienes que
seguir tu instinto.
No dudar de ti mismo.
Muchas veces piensas,
"quizás que no es correcto."
Pero hay que animarse.
De vez en cuando
vas a cometer errores.
Pero hay que seguir
nuestro instinto.
Si se dice así.
Martín: Exacto.
Si, exacto.
También creo que es una
manera mucho mejor
para aprender.
porque voy a poner
un ejemplo tonto...
Si yo quiero decir "yo tengo",
se dice "Ich habe" en alemán.
Pero acá la gente
no dice "Ich habe".
Dicen "Ich hab", cortan la e.
Dicen "Ich hab das gemacht".
"Yo hice eso".
Y así es con todo.
Como cortan todo
el tiempo las letras.
Comen todas las palabras,
eso pasa en todos los idiomas.
Y si yo me pongo a aprender
el alemán, solo de las tablas
y del diccionario,
cuando vaya a la calle,
no voy a reconocer las palabras.
Porque en el libro se
pronuncia de una manera,
y la gente lo pronuncia de otra.
Entonces para mí,
es mejor aprender escuchando.
Algo que también me funciona
a mí, no sé, a otros quizás no,
pero es escuchar y
leer al mismo tiempo.
Porque ahí pienso, esto
que se dice así suena así.
Steve: Pero hay que
tener esta experiencia.
Por ejemplo, el otro día
hablando con mi jardinero
aquí en Palm Springs,
es un mexicano,
él decía que había problemas
con el "Pao".
¿Pao?
¡Pago!
Martín: Ah, el pago.
Steve: Pago.
Yo no entendía.
Entonces, en todos los idiomas ocurre,
que comen palabras,
comen vocales, letras.
Y también quiero decirte que,
para mí, la cantidad de vocabulario
en alemán y en español,
es lo mismo.
Aprendiendo, tenía libros en mi
casa de español y libros de alemán,
en cada página había como
10 o 15 palabras que no conocía.
Era la misma cosa en los dos.
El hecho es que, para
leer cosas interesantes,
necesitamos muchas
palabras con poca frecuencia.
No todo el día en
el bar o con amigos.
Pero con películas o libros,
necesitamos muchas palabras.
Que sea español, que sea alemán.
Yo no sé si objetivamente necesitamos
más palabras en alemán que en español,
pero para mí,
parecían la misma cosa.
Martín: Ah, eso es interesante.
Porque yo lo veo
desde mi punto de vista
hispano, ¿no?
Pero si me pasa, por ejemplo,
que muchas veces hay palabras
que en español usaría una sola,
como por ejemplo en inglés,
la palabra "exit".
En español es "salida".
Y salida está por todos lados.
Pero acá hay una palabra
para salida a pie, "aufgang".
Y hay otra para salida
vehicular, que es "ausfahrt".
Entonces acá siento que usan más palabras.
Pero, en fin, igual hay que
aprender muchas, muchas palabras.
Y eso que tú dices de si quieres
tener acceso a mejor contenido,
o a mejores conversaciones, hay
que aumentar el número de palabras.
Y eso a veces, no
basta con "small talk".
Uno tiene que
escuchar o leer más.
Steve: Siempre están
aquellos que dicen,
"Basta con 1000 palabras
para la mayoría de los textos".
Eso no es la verdad.
Porque el nativo, tiene como
30.000 o 40.000 palabras.
Y tú no puedes controlar que
palabras él o ella va a utilizar.
Y para comprender lo que dicen,
necesitamos un gran vocabulario pasivo.
Siempre.
Otra cuestión...
Tú has leído el libro
"Hábitos básicos".
No, "Hábitos atómicos".
Martín: Atómicos, sí.
Steve: Yo también he leído
este libro y he hecho un video,
sobre la aplicación de este
video al aprendizaje de idiomas.
¿Qué piensas tú?
¿Hay cosas en este
libro que pueden ser útiles
a la gente que quiere
aprender idiomas?
Martín: Si, sí.
Ese libro es muy útil.
Lo primero que me viene a la
mente es
esto que habla este autor,
James Clear creo, ¿no?
Steve: Si, exacto.
Martín: El habla
sobre stocking habits.
Como apilar hábitos.
Eso a mí me ha servido porque
las personas se quejan todo el tiempo,
de que uno no tiene tiempo
para nuevas actividades.
Tengo que aprender inglés,
¿Pero, en qué momento de mi vida?,
no tengo tiempo, ¿no?
Y a veces, la solución
no es hacerse un espacio,
como romper tu horario
de vida y hacer un espacio,
sino simplemente insertar un
nuevo hábito,
al costado de otro.
Por ejemplo, no sé, que se
yo, por poner cualquier ejemplo,
me ducho siempre con podcasts.
Y cambié la música por podcasts.
Y ya no es algo que me
quita tiempo o esfuerzo mental,
simplemente yo sé que
entro al baño y pongo play.
Steve: Yo hago lo mismo, al
limpiar la casa escuchando. Siempre.
Corriendo, escuchando.
En el coche, escuchando.
Siempre.
Martín: Claro, claro.
Y también,
otra cosa que dice el libro,
es hacer las cosas fáciles.
O sea, no tanto hacer más cosas,
sino hacerlo fácil.
Entonces por ejemplo,
cada uno tiene su plataforma de podcasts.
Yo uso mucho Google podcasts.
Y lo que hago ahí es,
al comienzo de semana,
me creo una playlist.
Descargo todo lo que
quiero escuchar en la semana.
Entonces durante la semana,
ya no tengo que pensar
qué voy a escuchar,
sino que ya tengo un orden ahí.
Eso me ahorra mucho tiempo,
sobre todo, me ahorra mucho
la necesidad de
tener que decidir algo.
Simplemente lo
hago en automático.
Steve: Otra manera
de ver esta idea,
porque él dice también que
los cambios pequeños en la vida,
si continuamos mejorando
cosas aunque sea un 1%, un 2%,
la acumulación de los
cambios puede ser muy grande.
Entonces lo importante
no es hacer mucho,
"Un día voy a estudiar
como 4 horas", no.
Hay que estudiar cada día.
Poco.
Pero lo poco que estudias
a nivel diario, finalmente
termina siendo muchísimo.
Martín: Exacto.
Un ejemplo que se me
ocurre ahora mismo es que,
yo estuve leyendo mucho
en alemán,
para aprender,
y un día me tocó cocinar con un
libro
con una receta en alemán,
Y me di cuenta que
no entendía nada.
Entonces, es que el
vocabulario de los libros,
no es el vocabulario
de las recetas de cocina.
Entonces dije,
¿Cómo puede ser que teniendo
un nivel relativamente bueno
en alemán, no soy
capaz de cocinar algo?
Entonces dije,
"Quiero aprender el
vocabulario de cocina".
Y me propuse cocinar todos
los días,
con recetas en alemán.
Y no intenté aprenderme
todas las palabras,
aprendí una palabra por día.
La buscaba en el
diccionario, la aprendía.
Y después de un mes,
creo que ya puedo tomar cualquier receta...
Porque las palabras se repiten.
Todas las palabras de
cocina, los instrumentos,
eso se repite, ¿no?
Y no hizo falta estudiar una
lista gigante de vocabulario.
Con una palabra al día,
vas completando y vas avanzando.
Steve: Y el hecho de cocinar,
te da un sentimiento de éxito.
De haber hecho algo.
Siempre en la vida,
pueden ser cosas sin
relación una con otra,
pero si tienes un sentimiento de éxito,
de "accomplishment", ¿cómo se dice?
De haber alcanzado algo.
Eso es más
importante para nuestro,
ambiente espiritual, moral.
Nos da mucho.
Martín: Si, de motivación.
Steve: Por esta razón también,
tenemos que hacer cosas fáciles.
Para que lo podamos lograr.
Cuando tenemos éxito,
queremos continuar teniéndolo.
Y esto también
es muy importante.
Son cosas de las que, en este
libro, escribe también James Clear.
Bueno, creo que podemos continuar
hablando unas horas sobre este tema,
pero bueno, vamos a quedarnos aquí.
El alemán no es fácil.
Bravo, porque es difícil.
Es difícil pero si
vivimos en un país,
vale la pena, al inicio,
ponerse este desafío.
"¡Voy a estudiar este idioma!".
Voy a alcanzarlo a un nivel al
que pueda hablarlo con la gente.
Que la gente quiera
hablar conmigo en alemán.
Todo esto es muy importante.
Sobre todo,
en los primeros dos, tres años.
Seguro.
Martín: Si, y añadiría también
que creo que,
es muy importante
ser paciente y realista.
Porque yo lo que veo, es
que mucha gente llega acá,
como con muchas
presiones o urgencias.
Entonces uno tiene que llegar,
encontrar trabajo rápido.
O uno se siente a veces un
poco solo, tiene que hacer amigos.
Uno tiene que estudiar o
ingresar a la Universidad.
Y para todo eso,
el idioma es necesario.
Entonces uno se aproxima hacia el idioma
como "Lo necesito rápido, rápido, rápido".
Y empieza uno a ver estos videos en YouTube
de "Cómo aprender alemán en una semana."
Y no.
Creo que uno tiene
que ser realista.
Y un poco intentar mover ese
stress, y empezar a encontrar
qué es lo que a mí me
conecta con este idioma.
Porque si lo único que te
conecta, es que estás apurado,
que lo necesitas hacer rápido,
va a salir todo mal.
Para mí, creo que es más
eficiente encontrar desde el inicio,
qué me gusta, qué es lo que encuentro
interesante de este idioma, ¿no?
Steve: Tenemos que darnos
cuenta que el cerebro va a aprender.
Aprende, pero despacio.
Lento.
Es inevitable.
Y todo el stress,
es un impedimento.
Es el enemigo del éxito.
Martín: Exacto.
Steve: Ok, muy bien.
Gracias Martín.
Martín: Gracias Steve.
Steve: Hasta la próxima vez.